(Ray grunting)
(dog barking)
(indistinct)
(Ray grunting)
(Ray laughing)
(dog barking)
- Quit.
(Ray grunting)
- [Mark] So, what are your names?
- That's Jay, Lorraine, Timmy.
- I'm sorry, what's his?
- [Woman] His name's Ray.
- [Mark] Ray, I remember Ray.
I photographed you, Ray, do you remember?
Years ago.
And your name is?
- Lorraine.
- Lorraine
and Timmy.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- [Mark] Now you guys grew up
here in Odd, West Virginia.
How many years have you lived here?
- [MAn] (laughing) All her life.
- All my life.
- [Mark] You're,
you guys, I mean, did you go to school?
You did?
Some of your,
some of your brothers and sisters
probably didn't go to school?
Or how much schooling did they get?
- They didn't (indistinct).
But he graduated.
- [Mark] You graduated from what?
- [Woman] Woodrow Wilson High School.
- [Mark] You went to high school, Timmy?
- [Woman] Yeah, he went through
all high school (indistinct).
- [Mark] And how about you Lorraine?
- [Woman] Nah, she didn't went to school.
- [Mark] She didn't?
- [Woman] No, they didn't went to school.
(Ray grunting)
- [Mark] Come on out.
(woman laughing)
- [Woman] Come here, Ray.
- [Mark] Ray, tell me about your family.
(Ray grunting)
(dog growling and barking)
(dog barking)
- So Ray.
(Ray grunting)
- [Preacher] Examples of
God supplies our physical,
financial needs through people,
and there could be
multiple things happening,
but don't doubt that God has done it.
You start praising him
that it's a done deal,
and then you just stand there.
You know, sometimes-
- How do I turn that off?
(Ray grunting)
- [Preacher] You just have to stand.
It says over in Ephesians chapter six
that you take unto you
the whole armor of God,
having done all things-
- [Mark] How do I turn that,
do you know how to turn that down?
(dog barking)
- [Preacher] You just have to
take the helmet of salvation,
the breastplate.
(dog growling)
The spirit, the word of
God, and you just stand,
and you fight, and you
have to just stand there
until you see a manifestation.
Now I believe that there's
things that we can do
to speed up this manifestation,
but I hadn't got time to
tell you about it today.
I'm gonna have to do that on my programs
the rest of this week.
- [Mark] So Ray, tell me about where you,
- [Ray] Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
- [Mark] How old are you?
(Ray grunting)
How old are you?
How old?
(Ray grunting)
What are you eating tonight for dinner?
A sandwich?
(Ray grunting)
So you grew up here in Odd, West Virginia.
Your whole life.
(Ray grunting)
And your family, you lost your brother
since I was here last.
(Ray grunting)
- [Woman] Come on, Ray,
come out on the porch.
- [Mark] Tell me about your brother.
(Ray grunting)
- [Woman] Come out on the porch.
- [Ray] Hey, hey.
(dog growling)
(Ray grunting)
(dog barking)
(indistinct)
- [Mark] What's your favorite memory, Ray?
Do you remember anything about your life?
(Ray grunting)
- Hey, hey, hey, hey.
- [Mark] And you lost your other brother.
(Ray grunting)
So you lost your brother?
Ray's brother?
- Huh?
- [Mark] Ray and Tim's brother.
- No.
- No, Ray.
Timmy is our nephew.
- Oh Tim-
- Tim is our nephew.
- [Mark] Tim is a nephew.
But there's one of the
brothers that's missing now.
- Well, one of my brothers died.
- [Mark] That's what I'm saying.
Who was that?
- Freddie.
- [Mark] Freddie, that's right.
Freddie's gone.
How long ago did he die?
- He's been dead for almost four years.
- [Mark] Four years.
How did he die?
- Huh?
- How did he die?
- He he had a heart attack.
- Heart attack.
- His heart.
- And his heart.
- [Mark] So tell me about your family.
Your parents,
tell me about your parents.
- My parents died.
- Oh, of course, yeah, they're older now.
They'd be very old.
What,
what can you tell me about your family?
- Not much.
- [Mark] No?
You love your parents?
- Yeah, I love my family.
- [Mark] Good family.
(Ray grunting)
(Mark laughing)
Timmy, are you hiding?
So I hear stories about your family,
that your parents were brother and sister
or cousins or something like that.
Nothing like that?
But the mental disorder that
Ray has, what is that from?
- I don't know.
I don't know what cause 'em.
- [Mark] But Freddie and Ray and Timmy,
both have that same, and Lorraine, too,
has the same thing.
What do you suppose the
cause of that might've been?
- I don't know what cause it.
- [Mark] You don't know.
Timmy, you went to high school, right?
- [Woman] Get up.
Get up.
Timmy, tell me about what
you remember of your parents.
Can you tell me anything?
Lorraine, what can you
remember of your family?
(Ray grunting)
(dogs barking)
(indistinct)
(Ray grunting)
(dog barking)
Ray, do you remember
your brother, Freddie?
Freddie, your brother?
(dog growling)
(Ray grunting)
- Hey.
- [Mark] Ray.
(Ray grunting)
Your brother, Freddie.
Do you remember him?
(Ray grunting)
Do you miss him?
Do you miss your brother?
(Ray grunting)
What's over there?
What is it?
(Ray grunting)
Oh, is that Freddie's grave?
Is that Freddie's grave?
(Ray grunting)
All right, well, it was
interesting seeing you guys again.
Thank you for lettin' me come by.
You remember me from about 10 years ago?
- Yeah, I remember you about 10 years ago?
- [Mark] Yeah.
I'm sorry about your brother.
I'm sorry about Freddie.
Lorraine, Timmy, thank you
for letting me come by.
Ray, I'm gonna take off.
Thank you for letting me come by again.
Nice seeing you again.